la fraise c'est un fruit chouchou elle
est rouge elle est belle elle est
remplie de vitamines d'antioxydants mais
c'est une culture fragile qui nécessite
beaucoup de pesticides pendant des
années les autorités ont refusé de
rendre publiques les informations sur la
présence de résidus de pesticides dans
les fraises un manque de transparence
inquiétant aux yeux de certains
[Musique]
des images de pulvérisation de
pesticides il en existe plusieurs dans
des champs de maïs d'oignons de blé ou
dans des vergers
mais dans des champs de fraises c'est
beaucoup plus rare l'industrie
privilégie les scènes bucoliques et
préfère passer sous silence ce qui se
déroule en coulisses
le québec est le principal producteur de
fraises au canada chaque année
seize mille tonnes de petits fruits
rouges sont cultivés dans la province
le tiers des producteurs sont établis
dans la région de la capitale nationale
dont plusieurs à l'île d'orléans jean
julien plantes cultivées 27 hectares de
fraises à saint laurent de l'île
d'orléans
sa famille est dans le domaine depuis
quatre générations la culture des
fraises moi ça m'a toujours passionné
c'est quand même une récolte qui se fait
à la main donc beaucoup de gens on a
bien sauté si ça met de la vie puis on
est bien entouré donc c'est comme une
belle bête le tout l'agriculteur et sa
conjointe ont quatre jeunes enfants qui
ont grandi à la ferme
au fil du temps les parents ont commencé
à craindre qu'ils mangent
accidentellement des fruits sur lesquels
des pesticides venait tout juste d'être
répandu il y avait le droit d'en manger
aucun recrues dans les champs tant qu on
allait manger des fruits ce passe-t-il
pour une marche avec nous qu'on était
l'eau on leur dit oui vous pouvez y
aller c'est possible mais sinon on
prenait pas de poids n'a pas de chance
et nous voulons salle allumer des
lumières le chez nous tout est ce que
c'est parce qu'on veut vraiment un ces
enfants des pesticides on en voulait
plus le sourne eux sur la ferme
les fongicides herbicides et
insecticides font partie de la grande
famille des pesticides
ils servent à combattre les champignons
les mauvaises herbes et les insectes les
insectes comme les punaise terne les
tetra n'est qu'à deux points où les
drosophiles à l tacheté qui ravagent les
cultures mais tous ces produits
chimiques se faufile bien souvent jusque
dans notre assiette
depuis quelques années un palmarès
américain répertorie les douze fruits et
légumes qui contiennent le plus de
résidus de pesticides patate sellerie
thomas poires cerises pêches raisins
pommes nectarines qu'elle épinards et la
fraise qui bon an mal an trône au sommet
de cette liste peu enviable le québec
fait-il mieux le dernier rapport sur la
présence de pesticides dans les fruits
et légumes n'avaient jamais été rendues
publiques avant cette semaine par le
ministère de l'agriculture des pêcheries
et de l'alimentation le m'attaquent
à tel point que le vérificateur général
du québec déploré en 2016 que les
citoyens n'ont pas accès à toute
l'information pertinente en vient le
temps de faire le suivi de la présence
de pesticides dans les aliments
même les situe national de santé
publique du québec s'est fait refuser
l'accès aux résultats des analyses
d'échantillons de fruits et légumes
effectué par le mapaq pendant près de
dix ans
1st porter parce que c'est un sujet
d'actualité les pesticides sujet chaud
les gens veulent informer
on a développé des méthodologies de
travail notamment pour évaluer les
risques et on serait comme organisme de
santé
les intéressés à utiliser les données
propres au québec pour faire ces mêmes
exercices d'évaluation besoin
l'association des producteurs de fraises
et framboises du québec a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue est il la majorité
des producteurs que nous avons approchés
ont décliné notre invitation
nous reproduisons ici leurs propos on
veut pas voir l'image de celui qui met
du pesticide jade veut pas de publicité
là dessus ça prendrait des producteurs
qui n'ont pas de kiosques ou 2 to pay
est pour ne pas nuire à leur ferme
on est quand même assez chanceux que
sept étudiants sortent en hiver c'est
certain que si ça sortait pas dans nos
récoltes
on aurait justifié finalement un brave
qui a été délégué par l'association des
producteurs de fraises et framboises du
québec accepté nous rencontrer mais j'ai
vu c'est ça c'est plus avancé david côté
et producteur maraîcher à
saint-paul-d'abbotsford en montérégie
les fraises constituent 10% de sa
production
moi je sais que mon produit bon je sais
que la façon de chaumont agriculture je
l'aï fait dans la bonne direction
puis je suis là pour faire des fruits
s'en tire donc
ça me fait plaisir de parler de la
position de fries au québec la façon que
je produis je dis pas que c'est la
meilleure mais c'est le seul qui avaient
apprécié que j'aime faire
je la considère sans danger
l'agriculteur plèbe qu'ils ne mettent
pas de pesticides pour le plaisir mais
lorsque cela est nécessaire pour la
santé de ses plans la comparaison avec
les états unis
très peu pour lui et comment vous
réagissez vous à chaque printemps quand
est publié aux états unis la liste qui
place la france en tête de liste des
fruits et légumes qui ont le plus de
résumer steed s'enferrer ça ça me fait
vraiment rire parce que je trouve que
c'est le comparatif est polop david côté
fait valoir qu'au canada
les agriculteurs ont des pratiques qui
minimise les risques de retrouver des
résidus de pesticides sur les aliments
par exemple le délai entre le moment où
les producteurs applique les pesticides
et celui où ils sont autorisés à
récolter les fraises est souvent plus
long ici aux etats unis auront des
produits ici au canada à sept jours
avant récolte qui ont un bon côté de la
frontière
un jour comme quoi
ben ali fongicides à partir
aux etats unis
95 % de tous les échantillons de frein
est resté en 2016 contenaient des
résidus de pesticides du lot 5 %
excédait la limite permise
ces informations du département
américain de l'agriculture sont
accessibles à tous sur internet on peut
consulter les rapports et les bases de
données dans leur intégralité
mais au canada il n'existe aucun rapport
public sur la question
seuls les journalistes ont accès à une
base de données dans laquelle on apprend
qu'en 2018 80 % des échantillons de
fraises analysé au pays contenaient des
traces de pesticides
2 % du lot excédait la limite permise
ici au québec
le mapaq a accepté de nous transmettre
des données partielles issus des
analyses effectuées entre 2007 et 2016
les résultats révèlent que 80 % des
échantillons de phrases testés
contenaient les résidus d'au moins un
pesticide du lot 17% contenait plus de 5
résidus de pesticides dans un seul
échantillon dépassé la limite autorisée
même si on respecte les niveaux de
risques on peut observer notamment qu'il
ya certains de ses produits qui ont des
effets de ces potentiels o'neill samuel
a analysé la base de données que nous
lui avons fourni la liste des résidus
retrouver sur les échantillons fraises
ne l'a pas rassuré d'autant plus que
plusieurs de ces fonds jc des
insecticides n'ont pas bonne réputation
en avait une dizaine qui sont des
cancers jeunes soit possible ou probable
qu'ils ont d'autres propriétés aussi au
niveau des échanges aucune est par
exemple on commence à avoir beaucoup de
données qui demande que l'exposition
particulièrement pendant la grossesse
aux insecticides peut être associé à des
effets néfastes sur le développement du
cerveau des enfants
maryse bouchard explique que les limites
maximales de résidus de pesticides sont
déterminés pour chaque pesticide pris
isolément
elles ne tiennent pas compte de ce que
les scientifiques appellent l'effet
cocktail
quand on regarde la liste des pesticides
qui avait été retrouvée sur les fraises
en fait ce qui est remarquable c'est là
la quantité le nombre de pesticides
différents qui sont utilisés alors on
peut vraiment se poser la question quel
est l'effet combiné de tous ces
pesticides leur et gérer en même temps
sur un même produit
mais on commence à avoir des données la
turquie qui démontre qu'il ya vraiment
des interactions donc ça peut être
inquiétant l'association des producteurs
de fraises et framboises du québec fait
valoir que lorsqu'il y a des résidus de
pesticides sur les petits fruits
ce sont des doses extrêmement faible
deux cent à trois mille fois inférieure
à la dose qu'une personne peut ingérer
sans nuire à sa santé
dépendamment du pesticide et si santé
canada qui fixe les limites maximales de
résidus qu'un aliment peut contenir
santé canada au site c'est à eux qu'on
fait confiance c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment à côté de l'industrie de ses
poids des lobbys qui sont ensemble ils
travaillent de cette façon là un point
de vue que ne partage pas maryse
bouchard
raconte moi je suis pas complètement
rassuré quand je vois la façon dont les
normes sont établis ce qui est kate
maryse bouchard
ce sont les révélations de l' agence de
réglementation de la lutte
antiparasitaire de santé canada le
printemps dernier lors de la commission
parlementaire sur les pesticides
son représentant a expliqué qu'elle n'a
pas les ressources nécessaires pour
valider elle même les conditions
d'utilisation des pesticides
on a fait pour les autres nous est
généralement essentiellement des autos
de l'industrie il ya un manque
d'indépendance là dedans est tout de la
façon qu'on peut faire les études et
certains choix méthodologiques qui
peuvent faire qu'on va peut-être pas
observer certains effets donc
socialement d'indépendance qui à mon
avis pas souhaitable malgré tout les
scientifiques conseillent de continuer
de manger des fraises pour les bienfaits
nutritionnels associés à leur
consommation mais il faut absolument les
laver à l'eau courante pour éliminer le
plus de traces de pesticides
une pratique qui fait disparaître une
partie seulement des résidus
ce qu'ils nous disent quand l'avant les
fraises on retire la grande majorité des
pesticides c'est faux bah moi je crois
que oui il y en a certains c'est une
bonne pratique générale de toujours la
sphère où il va demeurer des pesticides
certains mais ça me surprendrait
beaucoup qu'on réduise de 80 % les
risques possibles du côté de jean julien
plantes
il a arrêté graduellement d'utiliser des
pesticides
il a tout d'abord fait des tests en
cachette de son agronome il mettait
moins de produits chimiques que les
doses recommandées chantier j'avais des
avis de traitement de très haute lutte
intégrée ou quoi c'est des fois je
vérifier mais j'ai tiré comme un
traitement oui j'avais un avis mais je
le faisais pas nécessairement tout le
temps puis c'est de même que je voyais
que dans le fond il n'y avait pas
d'effet gu10 pertes cette année laurent
faisant à présent si j'ai beau me
j'ai pris mon produit j'étais capable
quand même d'avoir une récolte superbe
gu10 perspective la dengue est question
d'argent mais aussi le lycée on peut
lire voir aussi
aujourd'hui le tiers de sa production
frais et biologiques
elle le sera entièrement en 2021
[Musique]
moins de 2 % des superficies de fraises
sont cultivées de façon biologique au
québec
à l'heure où le mapaq affirme que
l'industrie doit réduire son usage de
pesticides de défi est grand pour la
vaste majorité des producteurs
[Musique]